Hollywood week thanks for your live
Hollywood Week on American Idol was full
of moments that were heavy heartwarming
and hilarious one word to describe the
talent you've seen so far for season two
my word is
supercalifragilisticexpialidocious for
judge Katy Perry emotions got the best
of her during 27 year old Demetrius
Graham's audition my mother she is about
to have surgery tomorrow I just wondered
if I could FaceTime her and let her be a
part of this your son is about to sing
for us and we want you to be a part of
this moment as soon as Demetrius started
singing Katy got all choked up cause you
are the wind beneath
[Music]
nineteen-year-old colby swift crushed
his audition
singing in spanish no less st. the kitty
pen fell down
not only did Colby's vocals get him a
standing ovation from the judges he also
got a special gift from Luke Bryan
Colby can you show the camera the bottom
of your shoes there and of course you
can always count on Katy to get the
party started
she was so into 24 year old Alejandro
Arantes performance that she decided to
throw her clothes at him and Lionel
followed suit
[Applause]
[Music]
I never woulda thought Katy Perry would
be throwing clothing at me Graydon ET
has been covering American Idols since
day one here's what the judges told us
in November about season two's stellar
crop of talents this season of American
Idol people are taking it seriously and
with that a lot of amazing talent like
talent that I think should already be
signed or about record deals or they are
already artists or they probably have
tons of YouTube streams or a bubble up
there they're showing up for us and
using us as a mix as a platform to
launch like will will have these
contestants walk in and we're like what
have you been doing like how where have
you been
you